hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday yeah
[Applause]
September 25th
2023 what's going on how are ya
2023 September 25th a day that will live
in infamy in the drum worlds
um I believe that's the day John Bonham
passed September 25th 1980 rest in peace
still is badass as he ever was
people still sharing you know clips of
him soloing trying to figure out his
drum grooves and all that that was only
one
there'll never be another one
um so rest in peace
to John Bonham all right well here it is
oh my God
I'm not on the road everybody
um and guess what guess what I'm gonna
sit right down and watch myself some
football
and make believe I'm not married
I'm gonna watch three games right in a
[__] row yeah and play with my kids
during the halftime breaks Papa doopy
deep the halftime breaks bangs Zoom pow
that's all I'm doing today I'm watching
my Patriots right now well I think are
going to win big today even though it's
only three to nothing
we're doing all right this is a tough
time right now we're trying to figure
this stuff out I feel like we got a good
defense uh Tony Romo saying our offense
has gotten way better since week one
you know Mac Jones coming up to the line
what do we got 705 in the first [__]
quarter oh the old pitch it out he runs
up deceiver at first down there you go
that's what I'm looking I'm that's gonna
play right now that's gonna pay
dividends in the second half they're
wearing down this front four the New
York Jets and got a game of them do
um I feel like we're getting our we're
going to get our first win of the week
and you know what I love about the Pats
despite the fact that we're owing two we
do not suck was that Ezekiel Elliott
that might have been his first big run
of the year
I like it
8 304 career rushing yards
I got to tell you something he has the
cheapest looking visor I've ever seen in
my life
looks like the same material you know
when somebody goes as Randy Macho Man
Savage for Halloween
they just go to one of those costume
stores and it's like you know I was
gonna say the cheapest plastic
is there a higher grade of plastic
you know that they put in Mercedes
mercedes-benzes
um I have some dates to promote I'm a
[__] idiot I never promote my my my
dates on this because I always feel This
Is My Philosophy Bill what's your
philosophy could could you let us in on
what your philosophy is that didn't go
anywhere Jesus Christ in the backfield
um
My Philosophy is I just come on here and
be funny and then you guys will be well
God damn where is he
I got to go see this guy but that's not
how it works because you guys have a
life
well [__] Los Angeles charges up
seven nothing look at that
um all right yeah you guys have a life
you don't have time to go to my website
all right here's what I need I need to
sell some tickets on coming up uh this
week on the bus tour
um Springfield Massachusetts I was just
they uh it just worked out in the
routing so I'm coming back I'm gonna be
there on October 1st catch the [__]
ball
uh October 1st Springfield Massachusetts
at the Mass Mutual Santa
um and then oh boy oh boy I'm doing a
college gig oh I'll tell you the Hotel
this could be a rough one you know
um 10-4 good buddy October 4th
University Park Pennsylvania at the
Bryce Jordan Center
uh looking forward to that and then this
is this is the big one oh this is the
big one I'm gonna be in Canton Ohio
home of the Hall of Fame and the
original Arby's I think I know Canton
Hall of Fame yes Canton Football Pro
Football Hall of Fame October 7th at the
Tom Benson Hall of Fame Stadium it's a
football stadium they're cutting it in
half or whatever and uh I am really
looking forward
to these uh
to these shows and this tour
um
I got really inspired
you know doing that run over there in
Europe in fact my last show I'm going
out tonight though
I'm going out tonight all right go down
to the store I'm gonna do a couple of
shows okay shake the rest off like I
haven't gone up since I was in Greece
because then I came home and I was
hanging with my family and it turned out
I got the covid there
which is such a [__] pain in the ass
now because I think the virus has
adjusted because it doesn't want to kill
the host
this is what these guys say right these
scientist people
so now I feel like covid is now I'm not
going to speak on it because I'm not a
doctor but I feel like it's what
people were thought it was in the
beginning remember when they were going
oh [__] you're cold it's like I don't
remember losing my sense of smell and
taste
laughs
I'm [__] I don't remember somebody
dying from a cold but whatever you know
we were all [__] you know both sides
both sides had some rights both sides
had some wrongs both sides will declare
Victory that's how human beings are but
anyway
um so uh let's see I think I have like
one other date oh and then I'm gonna be
in Reno
I'm gonna be in Reno on October 28th
Reno Nevada at the Reno Events Center
um
I love Reno
let me tell me I love real you know they
shot Kingpin there
and I always tell you bizarre guitar and
gun shop one of my favorite things to go
to
and uh
and I just I don't know I like that top
it's a good time and it's right there
right right next door to uh it's not
Lake Mead what is it Lake Tahoe right
where they shot The Godfather
I don't like your kind with your
greasy hair and your oily skin remember
that Michael Corleone's looking at him
like dude I could [__]
could have you whacked during this
[__] meeting
you know I just love the complete look
of like nonchalance as he says all that
offensive [__] to him and he's just
staring at him like yeah okay
okay buddy is that what you got all
right anyway
um Oh Billy Oh Billy [__] Billy The
Aviator
I flew my ass off this week
I flew my ass off I flew Monday I flew
Tuesday I flew Wednesday and I flew on
Friday
and I might go up today
um
you know I always try to get my 10 hours
in a month just so I can uh stay
proficient and I had a uh
I had such a great time I flew up to
Santa Barbara I love that I have that
flight down now
you know I know when to get on with
approach I know how to get through all
the [__] airspace you know and I know
to follow you follow the 101
up North and then you you request City
pad you sat down if all the city pads
are taken up they got taxiway Juliet and
you can set it down there depending on
how long you're gonna be
um
come on Pat's how about a [__]
defensive stand here is that ball out is
that ball out
is that ball out
is the ball out
come on come on ah it doesn't look good
they're saying 20's got it
ah good for him
he looks dead underneath there
you know anytime there's a scrum there
like that for like the [__] football
a former player always has to talk about
like you know what goes on at the bottom
of the pile
oh there's all kinds of [__] look at
that look at that look at the Pats
forcing a fumble there
how the [__] didn't we get that
how the [__] didn't we get that that big
lineman came in and he punched it
towards him right there right there
that's what happened
why am I talking about [__] you guys
can't see
um
anyway uh
yeah so I flew up to Santa Barbara I did
the uh
Malibu Loop a couple of times landed at
uh Santa Ynez a couple of times I did
another one where I flew all the way out
to French Valley
which is fun
um until you get to the place where they
do the skydiving and [__] then I don't
know what frequency radio frequency I'm
supposed to be on you know one of the
planes is coming for a landing we were
like at the same altitude coming at each
other but you know you just turned to
the right
you know it's a little scary for half a
second you know but I have the avionics
going like there's somebody at your
altitude at 12 o'clock
[Music]
tackle him
go forth
fourth kicking from deep in your own
territory please don't be limping
Gonzalez
we got this kid number six they've been
uh
singing his praises
he shut down Tyreek Hill last week on
the Dolphins I mean we still [__]
lost
and it is still Tyreek Hill who by the
way I think had a 57-yard touchdown
against uh who the [__] are they playing
this week I don't know Dolphins man
I thought it was going to be the Jets
and the bills but uh and the dolphins
being the spoilers now it's looking like
dolphins and bills oh you think so Bill
what else do you think so anyway I got
like um
my goal this year was you know I only
have like because I take so much time
off
you know because I'm busy touring and
all of that and I'm you know I always
try to be safe when I fly so I always
make sure that I
shake the rust off I go up with my
instructor we go through the whole
[__] thing hoverados Autos stuck
pedal all of this stuff
um
and then I get going again and then I go
away again and blah blah blah so I only
have like
I had at the beginning of the year I had
like 36 hours
and change of solo time and I was like
[__] this I need to I need to get over
the hump all right
I'm gonna double this
you know by the end of March that's what
I said and of course I didn't because I
got busy and I got a wife and kids and
everything but now it's September
and I'm still trying to do it but now I
have I've gotten like
34 hours this year of solo time and um
that's what I do now I kind of just fly
solo and then once a week I try to get
with my instructor and I go through all
the autos and [__] which I think is good
because these guys I know that fly for a
living and like once a year they do
autos
so I feel like I'm being smart if once a
week I get up there
and go through the paces or whatever but
it's been
tremendous the next flight that I want
to do is I want to fly down
the coast down to like San Diego which I
was mentioning and I was all set to do
it
I had my frequencies
on my kneeboard I had him on this this
laminated thing that I had in the
passenger seat underneath the seat belt
in case my kneeboard falls off I had the
iPad I had the avionics I literally had
four levels so I wouldn't [__] this up
and it looked like the clearest day
I checked everybody's Taps which is your
temp terminal area forecast everything
was in the green everything was saying
eight to ten miles visibility and then I
[__] get up there
and it's all [__] hazy and all of
that and I'm like well you know when it
in the distance it just looks hazy when
I get up
closer I'll be able to see but then it
was just like I don't want to fly down
on a day like this I want to go down and
see all these sick ass [__] houses
along the coast because I always see the
ones
you know when I fly up towards Malibu
and all of that you know when I see all
these celebrities and and creators of
shows and [__]
you know I'm sure I flew by the Amazon
guy's house at some point just not
knowing it was his just looking at it
like who the [__] owns that
facility as Paul verzi says
um
so anyway uh very excited about that I
think I'm gonna get up there today
um in between some of these games or
something but I also gotta I gotta take
the kids to the playground and then I'm
also I'm gonna buy an underwater GoPro
because my kids are jumping in the pool
and they just do the coolest funniest
stuff when they're underwater like my
son jumps in the water
and when he when he goes under the water
he has a big smile on his face and he's
swimming towards me with one arm and the
other arm he's got he's doing the thumbs
up
it's so funny so I gotta make sure that
you know because they're going to love
seeing that someday so anyway
that's what I got going on uh uh Dion
Sanders let's talk Dion Sanders in the
Colorado Buffaloes took a tough loss
yesterday and uh I gotta admit is it me
or did they kind of set Dion up
it was ridiculous the guy was 2-0 and
he's on 60 Minutes
in fact he was they recorded it before
then like why are you putting them on a
2-0 it's his first year at this program
they're gonna have Growing Pains he's
created all of this excitement
two things I'm sick of with the Dion
story like first of all how much they
hyping the guy up
like there's no way he's not going to
get [__] because he's going to lose some
games I feel like they kind of set him
up to be to like fail a little bit or
he's just such a superstar that I don't
know there's ratings or anything but I
will say this as a white guy I'm sick of
mainstream White media telling me that I
don't like Deion Sanders and that for
some reason I have a problem with the
successful confident black guy coaching
a [__]
I don't give a [__]
and I think I speak for most white guys
when I say we like the guy he's
entertaining
he's [__] great at what he does I
love watching him play for the Cowboys I
like watching him play for the 49ers I
like watching him play baseball I like
that he's having success as a head coach
he's exciting
you're always going to find some [__]
idiots that are racists that don't like
him stop [__] feeding this [__]
story there's no story here do you
remember that time they had the gay
football player
the open the first openly gay football
player for [__] uh the Saint Louis
Rams and all they did was fan the Flames
of homophobia until finally one of the
linemen on St Louis was like yeah nobody
here gives a [__] you guys are the only
ones who care we're just here trying to
win football games and it kind of shut
the whole thing down like
um I think there's a lot of that going
on with this like uh you know I have a
lot of white friends I've yet to have a
white friend call me up and be like you
know how's your week going well you know
I be having a better week if Dion wasn't
being so successful coaching a football
team
so anyway
they took a tough loss congratulations
to Oregon and he's going to bounce back
and he's going to have more wins he's
going to have more losses it's up and
down but he's signed for five years and
he's going to turn that team into a
force because the guy's a [__] winner
and guess what as a football fan
and a white guy it's going to be fun to
watch
[__] [__]
they just like they do this [__] all the
time
and they always do it in like the form
of a question
like there's some controversy going on
about some stand-up comedian and
something that he I don't pay attention
to this stuff but you know rather than
like
coming out is the media and having the
balls to say we want to start censoring
stand-up comedy they do it in the form
of a question
they'll be like should comedians have
the right to exaggerate on truth
just opening up the discussion to every
mouth breathing [__] out there with the
keyboard
it's so stupid
it's so the whole thing
is just stupid all right uh
Alabama
bounce back with the wind what else did
I see Michigan won
I started to watch the Penn State Iowa
game and then my kids came in and
started just wanting to tackle me and
stuff which I'm not going to not do that
so I kind of missed the end of that game
and uh you know what I started to watch
but my Wi-Fi is all [__] up
I watched a great
um
I watched the great uh uh movie that I
always heard about growing up and for
some reason I was one of those movies I
thought I saw just because I heard about
it so much I'd never seen it uh Emilio
Estevez
and uh Harry Dean Stanton
in a Repo Man
and what a gloriously
weird offbeat [__] movie
and I gotta tell you something too man
like that period of cars some of the
ugliest [__] cars
I've ever seen in my life and one of
them
you know I always make fun of that Meme
going like back before this electric car
[__]
I love these [__] gas combustion
people that are so [__] afraid of an
electric car and they're acting like
electric cars are new like there was
electric cars right at the very
beginning they just got beat down by the
[__] oil companies
you know and now we're in the middle of
a 20-year War everybody but anyways
these electric car [__] we had these
muscle cars and everybody [__] walked
around with their dick and balls hanging
out which was really not the case
and all you need to do
first of all they're they're ignoring
the absolute horror
that was American cars from about 1977
to I would say about 93 before they
started making right making them right
again and one of the biggest offenders
one that everybody forgets about oh
where is it I I texted to Dean Del Rey
oh my God you got to see this [__]
car
this car look up it is the Oldsmobile
Cutlass salon s-a-l-o-n
it was like a four-door sedan on the
front
and then like a fat like a hatchback
it's like if a mullet was a was a
four-door sedan
it was business in the front and I don't
know what the [__] on the back
it was I remember when that car came out
I was like that is the ugliest [__]
everybody talks about the Pacer no one
talks about that and I I completely
forgot about the car
but it's the first car Emilio uh uh
without him even know knowing he repos
it uh but you should definitely check
out um
that movie such a uh
fun movie
um if you're in it's just sort of
something that's
I don't know I I only got like halfway
through it and then my Wi-Fi cut out so
I gotta I gotta rent it again
all right I'm watching this game here 15
minutes all right well it's the
beginning of the second quarter right
um and my nuts are are fans getting a
little crazy with the uh dressing up for
games
um
I love that people are in professional
football but there is
ah did he intercept that oh my God Jesus
Christ
it was almost a pick six with this Jets
[__] defense
um anyway
um
the level that people like I think when
you when you start
doing like
um
I don't know
like when you have on like more chains
than like Keith Richards more bracelets
or whatever and and you actually have
like a character name
you know I think it's time to dial it
back
there's just something that's really sad
about that get in that [__] goddamn
[__]
ah Jesus
I hate people that are excited about a
field Miss field goal on the other team
like you did anything
like what the [__] are you all amped up
about
it's not like you tipped it right
[__] son of a [__] this is gonna be
one of these ugly games I thought the
Pats were going to come out and win big
today
ah dag now but I missed it
look how excited this guy is
all right anyway
um
can you tell how bad the Pats need this
win
I need this win so [__] bad I'm so
sick of people not playing up to
Belichick's level and it's already
starting where like you know somebody
asked me going like do you think you
know the game has passed Bill Belichick
by it's like no I don't
that has got to be the worst take
ever okay he's got it he needs he needs
players man and he's getting him he's
slowly but surely getting them and and
things will be all right oh good he
missed that wide open number 17. that's
what I'm talking about Happy Feet there
Happy Feet and there's a sack
um
anyway what else what else did I want to
talk about what else was it that I
wanted to discuss I got my coffee
drinking under control
you know
um
I drink one cup a day
and I just enjoy the [__] out of it and
then if if for some reason
um
you know I don't know I'm overly tired I
have something else to do I'll just do a
little espresso that's it but I mean for
most part I just have the cappuccino in
the morning
and then look at these [__] sad ass
Jet fans
Jesus Christ they were so full of Hope
for four plays this season it's unreal
do you guys remember that that that sick
sitcom uh oh that wasn't even tipped
he just [__] threw it off yeah look
at that coach now he's not [__]
pumping his arms
um
do you guys remember that that [__]
sitcom Good Times
and uh I used I was watching that show
was on I was like eight nine years old
so I didn't know any better so I would
watch it and every time it seemed like
they were going to get out of that
shitty apartment I believed it and I
fell for it every [__] time
and then I thought they were finally
going to get out and then the dad dies
spoiler alert James Evans dies that's
what it's like being a Jets fan
[Applause]
every time they think they're gonna get
out of this
I mean this is literally been going on
for [__] I don't [__]
over 50 years
over 50 years 34 impressed with himself
Hardy senior
Hardy senior what the [__]
is Hardy Jr already doing something
now there is a man in his [__] that
is so in his ego that [__] guys
the name on his jersey said Hardy senior
I mean I can't even get mad at that
that's so [__] wow
you know what I like about that you
already know what you're going to get
before you sit down and talk to the
person so you know not there's not going
to be a surprise it's all going to track
um
anyways that's what it's like being a
[__] Jets fan
you know
I mean
obviously Joe Namath happened before me
but he wins the Super Bowl
and then immediately his arm his elbows
[__] up my 1971.
by like 73.74 he's a shell of himself
and he's on the [__] Rams and then
that's just it
and then who do they get they get
Richard Todd all right Broadway Joe and
then they call them Wall Street Todd
they so wanted to give him a nickname
they get the New York Sac exchange with
Mark Gastineau Joe klecco Maddie lions
and Abdul Salam
right here we go we're going to the
Super Bowl they're playing in Shea
Stadium
not Freeman McNeil Wesley Walker
nothing happens right and then they just
suck
they don't suck then then there's the 83
draft we take Tony Eason they take Ken
O'Brien
Dolphins take Dan Marino [__] 90
picks later we all know how that goes
somewhere along the line the bills get
Jim Kelly this is the history of the AFC
East right
the Pats and the Jets can't just can't
get out of their own [__] way
dolphins are riding out Don Shula
um
and then what ends up happening huh the
Patriots
Victor Kiam sells it
right
we get Bob Kraft he gets Bill Parcells
who gets Drew Bledsoe
Curtis Martin Ben Coates we start
drafting the right [__] guys
Vinatieri
and a man named Tom Brady in the sixth
round and then that was all she wrote
and the Jetstar in that time what did
they do huh they get Keyshawn Johnson
look at this poor bastard he's spitting
his [__] teeth out
guys spitting his [__] teeth out a
guy with a he had a partial
um
they get Finney Testaverde they get Bill
Parcells they have Bill Belichick and
Bill Parcells the winning combination
Benny Testaverde blows out his [__]
Achilles game one Keyshawn Johnson in
tears Bill Belichick the next year
Parcells is going up to the front office
and they want him to be the coach and he
gets out from underneath Bill Parcells
at the last second and goes to the
Patriots
now they gotta wait another year and
then comes [__] Rex Ryan talking [__]
players coach everybody's loving them
they got what's his fake face uh Mark
Sanchez
everything looks like it's going great
the butt fumble
find out he's in defeat it all goes into
[__] and now here they are
and they get Aaron Rodgers somewhere in
there they got [__] uh Brett Favre
yeah
look at the goddamn Miami Dolphins
winning again covering the [__]
spread
why the [__] didn't I take down this
week
um I took the patch though I can tell
you that oh Billy freckles took the Pats
getting tree
all right let's do some um oh no I got I
got one last thing I want to talk about
like okay remember how they they they're
sitting there trying to act like there's
all of these white people that are
annoyed
at Deion Sanders
nice [__] pass
you know
because he's charismatic because he
talks [__]
and he's a black guy and all of that you
know they're making up all like like oh
this is how you know white people think
rather than it's just a few I will tell
you something that I watched that I read
today that I did feel was racist a
friend of mine sent me this thing
about Miles Davis talking about Ferraris
and this guy's article
about Miles Davis and his love of
Ferraris
evidently he talked to miles for 25
minutes
okay oh
oh bam
that's what I'm talking about
hey Bill was that what you were talking
about that is what I was always nah he's
not happy now is he the Jets coach
oh my God
he should shave his head right now it'd
be the smoothest shave ever all those
little stubbles are standing up right
now what happened
what happened
safety getting over late number three he
[__] up somehow
and he is in he's in
does a wrist equal two feet you [__]
[__] don't do this to me
all right buddy come on here we go here
we go the extra point the extra point
you know I was talking the other day
because I had the Giants I bet the
[__] Giants Saturday night uh
Thursday Thursday night right
and um
I'll get back to that Miles Davis thing
and they [__] uh
the third goddamn quarter
they score a touchdown they're down by
five
ten minutes left to go in third quarter
they go for a [__] two-point
conversion why
it's like this [__] 25 minutes of
Regulation football left
kick the X to point right
here's the deal you kick the extra point
this is the other side that they don't
look at it's like yeah well now you're
down by four who gives a [__]
if you stop them
okay it's it was 70 it would have been
17 to 13. if you stop them and then you
go down and score a touchdown
then it's 2017. now you're up by three
because you kicked you kicked the extra
point I feel like going for two point
conversion like subconsciously is saying
to your team that you don't think you're
gonna get down there again so we got to
play desperate Madden football which is
funny because John Madden Madden mean
the video game John Madden always said
take the points so I'm talking to my
buddy about it he goes well you know the
analytics say that it's very rare that
you miss two two-point conversions in a
row and I'm like great dude great so you
missed the first one you get the second
one guess what you just got there two
points
you could have just kicked two [__]
extra points
rarely do you miss an extra point
like what people don't understand
because it's only for two points you
don't realize that like
when yeah when you're going for two
points you have to score and you're
basically trying to score a second
touchdown
if you look at it that way it's not that
[__] easy
it's funny because if you're on the goal
line and you're just trying to score a
touchdown people understand the goal
line stand
but for some reason they think the
two-point conversion is going to be
easier
from like the whatever the one yard line
then scoring a touchdown is like
psychologically
all right bill you talk about this every
[__] year I know so anyways getting
back to the Miles Davis thing which I
thought this was racist he talked to
Miles Davis for 25 minutes about
Ferraris
and it's only been in like recent years
uh recent months I should say that I
started to understand that like
not only did Miles
like crush it as a musician
crush it with the women he was with he
also long before everybody else back
when people were buying caddies and GTOs
and Mustangs and Camaros he was buying
Ferraris
and um and he bought some of the sickest
[__] Ferraris the ones that now you
know some of them go for upwards of like
10 million dollars
so I'm so excited to read this article
and I read the [__] article and all
this guy does
is [__]
on Miles Davis his attitude his career
he actually said when he was wasting his
time with fusion and avant-garde it's
like I'm sorry didn't he create Fusion
did he change music like
four times
Bebop
Bertha cool hard bop Fusion who the [__]
has ever done that nobody
and the whole time he had to deal with
all these racist [__] white people so
after a while yeah I don't want to talk
to you guys you're just going to write
some bad [__] about me anyway and then
the guy even said like that his
autobiography was a terrible last word
from him I read his autobiography It's
[__] amazing it's basically the
history of jazz
and you get to hear his side of the
[__] story so I'm assuming this
writer was white if the writer was white
okay you talked to the guy for 20
minutes about Ferraris I read your
[__] Article 90 of the [__]
article is you [__] on him and then
you give me two quotes from the [__]
conversation and that's the article
I don't know
see that one
I will go with
if if the writer was white and I'll and
I'll say that that guy
is either you know racist ignorant or or
something but this whole [__] story
that they keep feeding
you know that all these white guys are
sitting around hating on Dion we're not
we're not my whole [__] life Colorado
football has not [__] mattered the
way it's mattered now so thank God he's
there all right so stop [__]
this stupid [__] like that's all they do
is just try to divide us
all right I'm off my I'm off I'm off the
[__] stump there all right whatever
whatever bill just shut the [__] up and
read your reads okay
all right oh look who it is everybody
it's Helix sleep Alex
you know after being on the road there's
nothing more important than getting a
good night's sleep the Helix lineup
offers 20 unique mattresses including
the award-winning Lux or Luke's
collection l-u-x-e
um
uh the newly released
Helix uh Elite collection a mattress
designed for Big and Tall sleepers and
even a mattress made just for kids oh
they're thinking about the kiddo sack
that [__]
um so how will you know which Helix
mattress works best for you and your
body well take the Helix sleep quiz
and find your permanent mattress in
under two minutes and your personalized
mattress is shipped straight to your
door free of charge you know what we did
we [__] up we should have got a helix
mattress instead my wife ordered the
Craftmatic automatic adjustable bed
which I got to tell you like the first
day you're like oh wow look at me I'm
sitting up oh now my legs are up and
then you never do it again
but then you know it has like this this
you know
[__]
the mattress is split in half
so it's it's not good for your love life
you know what I mean I feel like my wife
is like a state away
like somebody has to like lay on that
thing you know
on the fault line in between the
mattress you got to go with Helix that's
what I'm saying [__] the Craftmatic
automatic adjustable bed
you know you might as well just be
sleeping in a separate twin
plus the Helix mattresses are American
made
yeah Maiden come with a 10 or 15 year
warranty depending on the model don't
want to take my word for it Helix has
been awarded the number one mattress
picked by GQ and Wired Magazine it was
even recommended by multiple
uh leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep Helix is offering
20 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
uh go to helixsleep.com and use the code
Helix partner 2-0
h-e-l-i-x-p-a-r-t-n-e-r-2-0 this is the
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts now oh
look who it is this is the last read
mercifully
look who it is everybody it's all zip
did you know that if you're hiring an
employer who's higher if you're an
employer who's hiring sorry the average
cost per hire is four thousand seven
hundred dollars
if you're investing that much money into
each new hire you want to get it right
so what's the most effective way to find
the best people for your roles OH ZIP
[Applause]
[Music]
see for yourself right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com
and experience the value that zipper
brings to hiring zip yeah gives you the
power to zero uh to zero in on top
talent
uh got your eye on an excellent
candidate don't worry zip recruiter lets
you reach out to them you can easily
send candidates your uh candidates
you're really interested in a personal
invite to apply you can slide into their
DMS to help your job Stand Out amongst
the competition it's simple zip
helps you get hiring right four to five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to this exclusive
web address to try zip
uh for free uh before you commit
ziprecruiter.com again that's
ziprecruiter.com spell outbur
ZipRecruiter
the smartest way to hire
God damn it I feel like a pro when I do
that last line it just really makes me
feel good about myself all right let's
see if we have the uh the reads here for
the week
um
oh guess what I'm gonna sit right down
and tape myself a special
and put it out on Netflix next year
that's what I'm hoping to do
um I think I already picked the city
and I think I already picked I already
know I have and I've already picked
the theater that I want to do it in
um so
I will give you a hint
wake up
that's a deep cut that's a 30-year
reference
um in that neck of the woods all right
uh MMP content
for 9.25
uh Bill great emails oh look look oh
look who it is
look who it is look at the goddamn Miami
Dolphins if you took the Miami Dolphins
today you got your flip us up on the
[__] table with a nice 21 to 10
comfortable lead
11 Point [__] lead but what was the
spread was kind of higher I just refuse
to believe that Russell Wilson is not
going to come back I just I can't like
him going from Seattle to Denver it was
like he had some major [__] injury or
something and he didn't did there's no
[__] way that's gonna happen oh
Christ I took the Titans look at the
Browns playing this week the Sean Watson
must have got [__] a rub and tug his
balls are empty he's out there flying
around the field all right greetings
greetings from uh Sweden hey Billy butt
cheeks
I love that Billy butt cheeks Burr
uh you've talked about that hookah chaka
song Oh you talked about it last Monday
Quentin Tarantino used that in uh
Reservoir Dogs that's right
I want to say it was when they were
going to get the taco they were in the
car
but it wasn't the version you think it
was a cover by a Swedish group called
Blue Suede not much happened with the
group after that but the lead singer
Bjorn shifts
uh
uh have since had a great career in
Sweden
oh well I'll have to look them up are
they singing Only in Swedish
hey I can't even do a Eddie Vedder
Swedish Eddie come to my Hospital have a
party oh yeah
um oh the kids are here I got I gotta
put on pause here what
okay and I'm back a couple hours just
went away
and I threw out my back
bringing my son up the freaking stairs
um
what the hell was I talking about well
before I get back into that question
someone was asking me once again the
prevent defense
strikes again
the Patriots have the goddamn game one
you know we can't make a first down so
we give the ball back to the Jets right
they're on like their own like [__] I
don't know what 30 35 yard line 40 yard
line or something we give Zach [__]
Wilson a 30-yard cushion
[__] wide receivers wide open I could
have made that pass if I could still
throw a [__] football that far they
complete it which gives them one Hail
Mary shot
at the end zone and guess what they
almost [__] made it
we knock it down it goes off a shoulder
a jet got a hand on it and it's just
like why did any of that have to happen
why the [__] did any of that what who in
their [__] right mind is afraid of
the Jets and Zach Wilson with [__] 22
seconds left
you just give them 30 [__] yards
and we almost we almost lost the [__]
game and guess what guess what the
boring ass Patriots versus the boring
ass [__] Jets comes down to the last
play and I'm on the edge of my [__]
seat which is why I still maintain that
the prevent defense was is a marketing
tool by the NFL that game was [__]
over
it was over wait a minute
you know what killed me is Tony Romo is
like oh and he completes it it's just
like Tony he's wide open
I get it Tony selling the game he's
selling the game but you know what oh
freckles ain't buying all right let me
get back to the thing here stupid ass
[__] goddamn
it's so dumb to bet on football I mean
I'm literally going up against
mathematicians with computers that
they're sticking algorithms into
you know
it's like I knew when we were up
13-3 I knew the Jets were going to get
another touchdown I knew they were
because the [__] spread was two and a
half three
it's like this isn't gonna be easy
like how do they know
what the [__] are they punching in there
I mean they probably they probably even
put the [__] dew point in to see how
much moisture is in the air
and what do I do I [__] make my bets
on Wednesday before the injury reports
are even out I'm [__] I have the
nerve to be upset that I'm not winning
bets
what a [__] stupid [__] I am all
right let's let's uh let's get back to
uh whatever the [__] I was talking about
all right the swedes the Swedish guy
here
um I have to ask you something you've
always had
shirts on
when performing
now at your last show in Stockholm you
had a white T-shirt and slightly wider
pants
you said that you were going to tell us
why that was but started talking about
something else and forgot why did you
break the trend did you spill coffee on
one shirt did it get lost at the airport
what the [__] happened to the shirt all
right before I forget that question what
happened is uh I went on vacation
over the summer my wife bought me a
bunch of [__] walk around Martha's
Vineyard clothes and I'm still wearing
them because
they're comfortable
you know that's why
you know because my wife loves me and
she was sick of me [__] wearing this
same black button-down shirt for the
entire 20 years I've been with her all
right one more thing uh it's been so
interesting to hear the evolution of
your mindset after mushrooms well
whatever
[__] positive steps I make
is lost when I have money on the [__]
game and they go into that stupid
[__] defense
I mean these [__] guys were backed up
40 yards people
because it's Zach Wilson and the Jets
were coming oh Jesus all right one more
thing it's been so interesting Evolution
all right I tried it not long after you
talked about your first experience can
an old freckled Ginger [__] like you do
it
I slightly younger [__] like me can too
oh I think you meant to say if
um boy was it an inner eye opener
yeah that's kind of fascinating for
somebody
from Sweden to take mushrooms
because you guys are pretty buttoned up
over out there you know
it's definitely you know thinking
logically and doing things that make
sense I can't imagine when the walls get
[__] blurred
um
this man goes on to say we rented a
cabin an hour outside of Stockholm calm
surroundings with forests and a lake
picture perfect that's amazing
oh I'm happy for you dude the great joy
and sadness it brought out of me has
helped me navigate a lot of things in my
personal life I'm telling they don't
call them magic mushrooms or nothing so
thanks for helping me take the leap to
try illegal substances
um I don't know dude I I'm I'm not a
doctor I'm not going to be some [__]
idiot podcaster acting like I am but uh
you know from what I've heard Mo I think
all of modern medicine has elements of
those mushrooms in them they're [__]
amazing and
I hope they don't become legal because
once the corporations get their hands on
them what they're going to do to it and
they'll change the DNA code and they'll
put sugar in it and [__]
fentanyl God knows what they'll [__]
put in it
um anyway
uh fat shaming dear Billy butt fat
first butt cheeks now butt fat what the
[__] is going on here
um I'm done with being nice to certain
fat people in casual conversation oh
geez this person's going in I'm tired of
seeing articles talking about how being
fat can be healthy and all that [__] I
work with the woman who's constantly
talks about how great she looks and how
great she feels because she goes to the
gym once a week but she is a lard ass
[__]
um
yeah you also don't need to react to
that I'm sure there's a lot going on
behind those positive statements anyway
in reality she needs to go every day and
stop eating for a while if she expects
any results also she thinks she's got a
great ass I know this because she tells
other colleagues all the time that God
that guys love harass
funny though because she also complains
about not having a boyfriend and how
guys don't respect her can have it both
ways you fat [__] oh Jesus her ass sucks
it's just fat no shape if it was great
dudes would be on it and never let it go
am I being too harsh yeah you sound
Young
I was like that when I was a younger man
um
you know her walking around saying she
looks good and all that is probably
because she cries herself to sleep with
a vat of ice cream every night I mean
that's what usually happens with most
people that are walking around
you know sayings things that clearly
aren't so
um you know what I would just be nice to
her
and I I would try to figure out what's
going on in your life
that makes
her annoy you to the point that you're
thinking about calling her a fat [__]
like I know when I was younger and I was
much [__] angrier some positive type
of [__] cinnamon roll eating jackass
like that would really annoy me
you know because misery does love
company and then she's sounding happy
so that would that would just be enough
for me to just you know
think something or say something or
whatever but like uh
I'd say both of you have a lot more than
a lot more going on
yeah work on yourself let her deal with
the cinnamon rolls and let you know
let her have a cake and eat it
[Laughter]
uh she's got a great ass
not really
um
okay that was mean what am I supposed to
do I gotta improv off what you guys sent
me here all right co-worker [__]
[__] co-worker [__] man
um hey Bill I need to vent a bit more oh
an airplane not leave it yeah another
Zeppelin another Zeppelin reference no
the guy's back on the throttle
hey Bill I need to vent a bit about my
co-workers I work at an office where we
all have different roles I'm pretty
quiet but if you engage me in
conversation I open up I work with wow
that's that covers a lot of ground
he's over there quiet like hey man how's
it going oh dude I was eating this
hooker's ass last night all right dude
it's a little [__] a lot of
information I work with a guy who was an
absolute [__]
oh God that's
how do those people get work
anyway the guy goes on to say he doesn't
know what he's talking about half the
time and when he does it's because he's
repeating stuff he heard from our boss
oh that's why they hired him
he's a [__] dope that wants to be the
teacher's pet now that's the perfect
employee
you know never going to Rebel never
going to quit
just smart enough to put the widget in
the [__] fallupal
um I read a lot and according I read a
lot according to my boss my two degrees
and my understanding of my job
I'm not full of [__]
wait I re I read a lot and according to
my boss my two degrees and my
understanding of my job I'm not full of
[__]
all right what's going on here you don't
like this guy and now you're [__]
regurgitating all your accomplishments
to me I don't know who to believe in
this so far I don't know
what just happened
there we go
I don't know everything but I spin okay
that's a little humble all right back on
the right side of the road
um but I spend my free time learning
about things I'm interested in uh
instead of drinking every night and
going out with my college friends I'm
not bragging it's just how my life is
going right now I've I flaked off in
high school but made up for it since I
read a book a week and listen to
audiobooks during my commute every day I
gave up on shitty Sports Talk years ago
so the hours are filled with interesting
stuff this isn't something I should feel
sorry about
well who's telling you you should feel
sorry about it
if ever I'm engaged in a conversation
with anyone in the office and I expel
any knowledge this guy will start
talking [__] and call me and know it all
oh there it is there's The Smoking Gun
oh yeah
dumb and Loud that I hate to say it but
they they go hand in hand
you know what I mean
you know it's like smoking and drinking
dumb and loud
right bacon and eggs it's just all
it's the rule of twos uh
last week
uh fat and [__] you know you fat [__] it
just goes together last week a girl I
work with mentioned she watched the
documentary about ancient Rome and I
offered some additional facts from a
book I read about every day Roman Life
pretty basic stuff like how they built
the aqueducts nothing controversial the
[__] chimed in and said something
like you think you're the brains of
every conversation we have don't you
keep in mind these conversations never
include him and he's always butting in
oh this guy's fantastic
listen don't fight this guy have fun
with this guy
you should be like oh I'm sorry yeah
you're right why don't you finish
talking about the Romans
um
or I'm just trying to keep up with you
you know there's zippy
little Ziploc bag with your peanut
butter and jelly sandwich in it this
yeah I just feel like he has like a
kid's lunch with like the crust cut off
and everything anyway I hate people who
can't understand that maybe there are
people who read books and like to learn
what should I say to this [__]
just look at him be like listen I'm so
sorry I read
I'll try to do less of it
if ever you think I'm reading too much
you just let me know and I will stop
reading that's what you have to say
um
yeah like
I mean this seems pretty I mean he's not
your boss right
you think you're the brains of every
conversation we have don't you and you
could be like no that was just a little
fact about Roman life that I happen to
know
what are you getting so upset about
or you could just go hardcore going like
listen
other than for you no one here it's no
secret that you're the dumbest [__] here
now you can't do that
why don't you just tell them to shut the
[__] up can you do that anymore
can you do that like like I don't know I
mean at first I thought he was an
[__] then I was thinking maybe you
were an egomaniac with you know bringing
up your education
but you really brought it home like I I
actually I actually have a picture of
what this guy looks like and I don't
like him
just agree with them
just be like yeah you're right I do I I
do think I'm the brains you know what it
is it's just I'm really insecure when I
get around a big brain like yourselves
you know
do you read a lot or does it just come
natural I would just do that
I would just sarcastically compliment I
would make him a hero
just be I'm sorry man I just you know I
get nervous when I'm around you I just
really look up to you in your intellect
um
anyway
how do you have time to read both
burning through all those [__] 12
packs all right music that is hell oh
this is like this has been a really fun
topic here
oh which by the way speaking of music I
got a band for you that Josh Homme
recommended
um
I think they're open for uh Queens of
the Stone Age right now the Viagra boys
uh Josh mentioned them on the podcast
and uh
I kind of circled back to that this week
I downloaded
um
let me see the name of the album here
um anyway I can't they're [__] great
they're great and their lead singer in
the lyrics are smart and hilarious and
the lead singer seems like he's a little
bit crazy so it's like the perfect
recipe for for a killer front man and
the band sounds incredible uh let's see
cave world
and what I like too is there's a bunch
of different
Vibes on it
like troglodyte which I had to look up I
thought the whole album was gonna sound
like that and then punk rock loser
sounds completely different
um
big boy I like ads stretch my arms only
friend it's just a [__] great album
came out last year they're on tour right
now
with Queens of the Stone Age and then I
think they're doing a a I want to say
Pacific Northwest because I was trying
to see if our paths would cross because
I would love to see them live check them
out the Viagra boys
caveworld deluxe edition is the album I
downloaded all right
now that we've done that let's make fun
of some music here all right music that
is hell
dear Billy Freckle tits all right it's
off my ass now now it's my tits uh am I
transitioning like what's going on here
with all this body shaming uh writing
from Montreal Canada love the bit
discussing terrible popular songs all
right if you guys haven't listened in
the last couple weeks we're talking
about
songs that makes an entire crowd of 60
000 people light up they just the look
in their eyes is like this is why we're
alive and you absolutely hate the
[__] song
um and my vote was that that song by
Queen
um uh Bohemian Rhapsody
that and then I also hate when Mony Mony
comes on
and some fat titted [__] my age
has to scream get laid get [__] I just
ugh
it's awful by the way Generation X can
we stop acting like we're these badasses
because we didn't wear helmets when we
rode bicycles you know we didn't fight a
war
Vietnam ended and then everyone was gun
shy about trying to get the [__] war
machine up again so we didn't have to
fight a war except for volunteers that
joined the military and we had like a
14-day War
in uh what 91 I think
you had like a 10-day war and that was
it
so these kids today that you're saying
are soft they've you know a lot of them
fought in a war and now live under a
bridge
you know I know we went skateboarding
without a helmet but
I don't think that makes us tougher
um all right greetings from Sweden
uh oh no wait this just went all the way
back to the Top Again [__] co-worker
[__] oh music that is Hell dearly
Billy Freckle tits okay as a big Stones
fan Start Me Up makes me want to vomit
every time not sure if it's because it's
always played at sporting events but it
is absolutely nauseating there's nothing
musically interesting in it
I like that song
maybe it's because they open every
concert with it
that's also like
I feel like the last
Rolling Stones record where they no no I
would say the one after that
Undercover
undercover Road that's a good song she
was hot they got some good songs on that
one um
one hit to the body I wasn't in that
steel wheels was all right
I love that album though tattoo you
that's [__] second side
oh my God
it's [__] dropped a needle and do
some drugs [__] fantastic
um
your drug of choice all right so this
person doesn't like that I could not
have agreed more with the nonsense words
with uh who got Shaka and Come On Eileen
can we add I Am The Walrus to this
category cuckoo kachu
um
if you know the history of that song I
think John Lennon was saying that we
could literally sing anything at this
point
and it would be a hit
so that's what they did I am you and you
are me and we are here together I am the
Eggman I am the Eggman I Am The Walrus
cuckoo cachoo it's just like yeah that
was deliberately
supposed to not make any sense this
person says I'm a large beagle fan but
just nonsense lyrics which is a trend
with them I suppose hell why not throw
in the end of Hey Jude which I do not
love though
uh hope to see you in Montreal again
soon best and go [__] yourself
um
I can't um
I can't argue with anything that you say
in there but I do like that song I Am
the Walrus
because what I like about is it makes no
sense but it just has this great build
I am the Eggman I Am The Walrus like
okay we've arrived where are we what are
we talking about and then to find out he
was just [__] with everybody I always
thought that was funny
um Rocky Raccoon all right awful song
all right hey Bill I have the utmost
respect for the Beyonce
for the Beyonce and as a black man I
shouldn't be talking any [__]
well this is the whitest podcast to ever
see is safe here talking any any [__]
about our supposed queen bee but I can't
stand most of her music
it might be because you ruined it
for me when you compared her
choreography to military ranks
I don't remember doing that there's so
many [__] people I've made fun of
just trying to fill up this hour I don't
even remember that uh or because my
entitled ex-girlfriend blasted it every
morning before her brainless job I would
think that that's what it is
if I hear Single Ladies one more time
I'm gonna have to be a single man for
the rest of my life
love Jay though Jay-Z yeah love from
Jersey yeah I know what you mean there's
a lot it's a lot of uh
you know female anthems
which are good but you know it's not
even Beyonce it's the people that sing
along
oh the late is independent throw your
hands up at me and all the hands go up
and you're looking at some people go say
you do not look independent to me you
look codependent
ha ha ha ha
and then I always thought the lyrics was
weird if if you if you liked it then you
then you better then you should have put
a ring on it
and it's like that's all somebody has to
do like in it's not love there's not a
connection you're the person I wanna Hey
listen first person that sticks a giant
rock on this finger I'm gonna [__]
marry him
you know I thought she was selling
herself a little short
um
I don't know I do find it funny like if
you make fun of her or you make fun of
uh
the other one there the white one
who's making those billion dollars what
the [__] her name
Travis Tritt this begins with a T
um
oh it's right on the tip of my tongue
it's it's a hottest [__] ticket of
the Year everybody wants to go a
Dixieland dog
she was dating to Kennedy
she bought a property down by the
compound they broke up she got rid of
the property
lose the Kennedy but you keep the house
why would you get rid of the house
oh my son's flipping out
I gotta see what's going on
um all right that's the podcast here
what the [__] is her name not Christina
Aguilera
you want to come outside buddy
you want to come out play with you all
right hang on a second all right that's
the podcast everybody go [__] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday